cohérent stéphanie chabat alors vous
êtes militante féministe et membre du
comité national de nous tout vous le
césar à romain de polanski c'est pas
vous êtes choqué c'est au-delà non c'est
au-delà oui alors déjà il ya une chose
qu'on entend partout et qui est
totalement fausse il n'a pas été
condamné a encore aux états unis il a
fait 43 jours en garante des psychiatres
hic et il s'est enfui
donc c'est déjà s'il ne s'était pas en
fuite il avait été condamné s'il avait
purgé sa peine si ça se trouve
aujourd'hui on ne serait même pas autour
de cette cession serait passé de film
peut l'assurer certainement de très beau
film sur dreyfus parce que y'a pas
besoin forcément d'un polanski
d'ailleurs donc déjà à il faut pas
oublier qu'il ne peut vivre que dans
trois pays uniquement parce qu'il est
recherché dans tous les autres pays
donc ça aussi c'est quand même y penser
selon ses dires de leur dire bravo c'est
fun donc en france effectivement on lui
déroule le tapis rouge bon il n'y va pas
d'accord mais parce qu'on a réagi et
j'entends ce que vous me dites monsieur
à une époque
effectivement on agisse autres moi aussi
je suis j'ai l'âge que j'ai et moi quand
j'étais jeune je trouvais matzneff
particulièrement beau figurez vous voilà
eh ben j'ai grandi j'ai vieilli les
choses évoluent et aujourd'hui matzneff
sa place effectivement derrière les
verrous sur ou peu changé aussi c'est
pas parce que c'était comme ça ya 40 ans
on peut continuer à l'excuser
aujourd'hui on réclame justement que les
choses changent et par exemple adèle
haenel elle y est allé et elle est
partie mais heureusement qu'elle est
allée elle est victime et ça n'était pas
à elle de se cacher elle est actrice
elle est invitée elle va elle est
victime et a le droit je joue dur à moi
je vous dirigera délais on va on va en
parler dans un instant ratez rien fait
quitter la salle on en parlait dans un
instant stéphanie j'aimerais juste vous
sur le sur le césar de romane point est
ce qui vous dit quoi alors sur les césar
je voudrais inviter votre action tout de
suite à quand vous avez vu qu'il avait
eu le césar j'ai réalisé effectivement
débouté désespéré et je me pose la
question est-ce que à c'est vraiment
parce qu'ils ont trouvé que ce film
était merveilleux ce dont je ne poussais
par vocation vous d'où est ce que c'est
une provocation effectivement en disant
voilà vous ne voulez plus que nous
fassions notre travail comme avant
puisque toute l'académie y a
à démissionner on va faire un dernier
baroud d'honneur et franchement je
n'arrive pas à trancher
il est vrai que le message qui a été
envoyé à toutes les victimes c'est
effectivement été tué violé par un
pédophile minel et ben écoute désolé ma
peau fille si c'est un super réalisateur
il sera pas condamné et quelque part ça
nous a pris six mois chez sa maman de
deux ados effectivement je me refuse
avec voilà sur une pub c'est normal ça
et je peux comprendre je peux comprendre
ce que vous ressentez stéphanie et c'est
très clair quand vous quand vous
l'expliquer et c'est vrai qu'à vous
parler en tant que maman de deux ados il
y en a plein il ya plein d'autos
d'autres mamans qui ont pensé comme vous
rêvent pense volet qui sont dit c'est
pas possible voilà moi si j'avais été
maman d'une victime
j'aurais vu ça j'aurais été voilà c'est
vrai que mine de rien j'aurais été
écoeurée de 2 ce qui s'est passé il ya
de mieux apprendre à aulnoye michelin
j'aimerais juste qu'on s'amuse à faire
quelque chose que votre discours est
parfaitement sensées viadère admettons
que on a affaire à pasteur le grand
scientifique pasteur et qu'il invente le
vaccin contre la rage oui et tout d'un
coup on va voir si on lui remet le prix
nobel de fûts de médecine ou pas on est
en face de quelqu'un qui sauvent des
vies et qu'il n'a pas violé d'enfants
pasteur c'est de la science fiction et
on s'aperçoit rien d'étonnant à voir dès
qu'il s'aperçoit qu'à des plus grands
scientifiques de tous les temps et
pédophile a violé des enfants
est-ce qu'on lui donnerait ou pas le
prix nobel de médecine il aurait fait du
bien l'humanité quand même fort mais non
et vous êtes d'accord qu'il aurait fait
du bien à l'humanité quand même il est
ce que j'essaye de mounir a utilisé son
vaccin ne lui aurait pas donné clôture
et bien c'est la même chose si c'est
exactement la même chose
c'est à dire que on peut considérer et
je le martèle que une oeuvre soit au
dessus de la personne qu'ils créent et
un [ __ ] peu ferdinand oeuvre parce
que c'est un des billets que la nature a
inventé pour ciat rachel amis de
critères et donc on revient à ce cas de
figure précis qu'une oeuvre est toujours
supérieur à celui qui l'a créé et qu'une
fois qu'il l'a créée si vous voulez elle
ne lui appartient plus et dans le cas de
polanski ya quelque chose assez
troublant comme à l'oeuvre comme à
cannes en mai je sais bien le
réalisateur et mai et bien voilà on
aurait possible pour twilight
10e minute de jeu est-ce que vous auriez
préféré qu'il soit meilleur film que
meilleur réalisateur oui eu un bon mois
mais y arriver il va pas changer oui en
permanence à venir la base et madame dit
un truc très juste son show mais très
très juste
je crois que il y a dans le fait d'avoir
couronné roland de polanski un effet de
provocation qui que l'ancien faut
toujours penser contre soi même
même quand on a eu vingt trente ans
quarante ans au 20e siècle
le xxième siècle faire procès au 20e il
ya des choses injustes dedans mais aussi
des choses vraies faut penser contre soi
même et je crois qu'ils aient une
réaction presque médical comme un
anticorps l'ancien monde à résister une
dernière fois où nouveau monde et je
crois qu'à un sursaut là qu'il ya
quelque chose qui ne passe plus derrière
les faits de provocation
moi je vous dis roi gt gt il ya j'ai
déjeuné avec tes potes
avant-hier et la réaction de mes quatre
potes à table ça a été je vous dirais
l'éclair ils vont tous dit je comprends
pas ce mec là il a fui les états unis
il arrive en france juste la première
question qui m'ont posé des toits qui
est du métier et me prouve encore des
films shrek la voix c'est le seul truc
qui m'ont ils m'ont dit tu me dis moi le
seul truc que je comprends pas je reçois
pas les sales trucs qui m'ont dit j'ai
maudit mine de rien le mec il a été
condamné il a fait 43 jours et ici il
s'est enfui pourquoi il faut encore
deviné c'est le seul truc c'est la
raymondie sont d'ailleurs pourquoi moi
je veux dire la grande question que tout
le monde se pose noah on va arrêter de
faire des hypocrites ici les yeux giuly
et moi c'est ce que se disent les gens
voilà qui sont pas du métier
ils disent pourquoi on a financé ce film
c'est tout le film à doc si le film
j'accuse et la cause est magnifique pour
toi mais réalisé par roman polanski
c'est de faire le film j'accuse oui à
peut-être réalisé par quelqu'un d'autre
c'est moi je vous ai fait le porte
parole de ce que je vois sur les réseaux
sociaux
sa survie n'est pas là
valérie pécresse qui s'est réveillée
hier matin et qui a dit ah bah je
regrette d'avoir financé le film elle à
la cera mais hier matin c'est amer
dallas dû boire avec ces merdes c'est
luca en finance et en train de me dire
que c'est moi qui est financée oui oui
on m'annonce qu'il quitte cette émission
la région dit un truc intéressant dans
un cabinet sans devoir me lamente qu'on
vous savez les 3 millions qu'on a
données au sein des services financiers
et les films par le biais du cn six lots
que mine de rien ça mais il pourrait
vous les choses iraient que quand même
quand on nous donne yeah man pour une
nouvelle série